What's playing out on headlines and
television screens today in Venezuela is
a confrontation with the narco-
dictatorship. It began in 1998 when Hugo
Chavez was elected. He immediately
began to dismantle the democratic
institutions of Venezuela, and consolidate power
into the hands of the executive. That
revolution also made common cause with
narco-traffickers, with terrorist
organizations, with hostile regimes. Before
he died in 2013, Chavez designated Nicolas
Maduro as his successor, and Maduro has
used brute force to hold on to power. In
2015, the democratic opposition won in a
landslide in the congressional elections.
Unfortunately, the regime has done
everything it possibly can to
consolidate its own power and to prevent
the Democratic National Assembly from
operating. We're in the midst of a
political crisis now, as you have a clash
of these institutions between the strong
executive (which is really a dictatorship),
and the National Assembly,
representing a democratic opposition.
What are your thoughts about the crisis
in Venezuela? Please let us know in your
comments, and also let us know what other
topics you want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.